on Tuesday the opposition control
legislator starts the impeachment
process against the conservative
president bringing to a boil a long
simmering political crisis
your position believes it has the Super
majority of 92 out of 137 votes required
to remove the former Banker as president
his administration has been besieged by
scandals deteriorating economic
conditions and a tide of drug-related
killings
ecuadorians on the streets are as
divided as ever I think he should go in
a democratic and legal way the Congress
is representing the will of the people
this government has only destroyed our
health and education systems
lasso should finish his term the people
18 million ecuadorians voted and he won
a majority we should let him finish his
work
lasso is accused of corruption related
to the embezzlement of funds and
contracts signed with a state oil
Transfer Company
his supporters deny the charges
describing them as politically motivated
this would be nothing short of a
parliamentarian coup they're trying to
remove him with strained far-fetched
evidence remember that this contract was
signed in 2018 by the previous
government investigators have found no
penal responsibility so there can't be a
political one
the leading impeachment congresswoman
says that this is just one of a series
of corruption allegations surrounding
the president's Inner Circle and it has
become a referendum on his government
this is no coup we're not trying to
destabilize the country its response to
a demand by citizens A desperate clamor
for a constitutional solution to a
problem called Guillermo lasso the polls
showed that after the issue of security
the biggest problem for ecuadorians is
lasso as president lasso said he will
appear before Congress to defend himself
but he also vowed to dissolve Congress
and call for early elections against the
impeachment vote triggering A peculiar
constitutional Clause known as Mutual
debts that has never been used before oi
that is triggered lasso will remain in
office for another six months governing
by decree but analyst Fiera could spark
further protest similar to those last
year over the rising costs of living and
further instability with rock a country
already adrift and ice
[Music]